♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la plus grande ville
des États-Unis. Une ville
où on se targue constamment
d'être à l'avant-garde en
matière de mode, de cuisine,
d'architecture et maintenant
sur le plan sanitaire.
Une première à l'échelle
du pays, dès lundi, restaurants,
gyms et salles de spectacle
ne devront admettre que
des clients ayant reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin
et, dès le mois prochain,
des contrôles gouvernementaux
seront mis en place.
(en anglais)
"Cela aidera nos petites
entreprises à rester ouvertes",
dit celle-ci.
(en anglais)
"Les gens seront plus à l'aise
de fréquenter les restaurants",
ajoute cet habitué.
Celle-ci s'en prend
aux non-vaccinés.
(en anglais)
"Ne veulent-ils pas
retrouver leur vie d'antan?"
En fait, ceux qui rechignent
le plus sont les restaurateurs
eux-mêmes.
YOHANN PÊCHEUX, propriétaire,
St Tropez Wine Bar
- Moi, ça me gêne
personnellement parce que
je ne suis pas policier.
On offre de la détente, on offre
du bon moment. On n'a pas envie
de demander aux gens de sortir
leur téléphone, de nous montrer
s'ils sont vaccinés ou pas.
S'ils sont huit personnes,
il y en a sept qui sont
vaccinées, il y en a un qui
l'est pas... ça va être...
ça va être compliqué.
- Certaines salles de spectacle
ne semblent pas non plus
très enthousiastes.
"On nous instrumentalise, dit
cette directrice de théâtre,
pour forcer plus de gens
à se faire vacciner."
"Surtout qu'on ne sait pas
encore, ajoute ce porte-parole
de l'industrie de l'hospitalité,
comment réagiront
les New-Yorkais. La mesure
entraînera-t-elle plus ou moins
d'achalandage? Mystère."
Vérifier le passeport vaccinal
ne sera pas le seul souci
des restaurateurs new-yorkais.
Ici aussi, la rareté de la main-
d'oeuvre donne des sueurs
froides aux propriétaires
d'établissement, poussant
les salaires à la hausse
et réduisant les profits.
C'est sans compter
l'augmentation du prix
des aliments et la nécessité
de rembourser les dettes
contractées durant la pandémie.
Ici Hugo Lavallée,
Radio-Canada, N